electric vehicles have evolved a lot
over the last decade what started as an
effort to produce environmentally
friendly cars has now changed into a
race of who can make the best electric
car electric vehicles started as these
slow low range vehicles that only super
environment and carbon emission
conscious people bought even then these
vehicles were exorbitantly expensive and
didn't offer people an acceptable bang
for their buck all this changed with the
creation of tesla tesla is
single-handedly responsible for
rebranding the entire electric vehicle
industry and revamping the hype around
electric vehicles a byproduct of this
increased hype has seen increased focus
in the world of electric supercars
resulting in the production of some
truly spectacular machines almost every
major car manufacturer is investing in
electric cars right now and has done
more than just step foot into this arena
luckily for you we've got a list of the
top contenders in this race to be the
best
as park owl
with a name just as awesome as its
performance the azpark owl is a beast on
the road the acceleration is a
mind-blowing 0-60 miles per hour in just
1.69 seconds as for the looks you can
see for yourself just how futuristic it
looks
like something straight out of a comic
book the asparc owl is the textbook
definition of a supercar it's fast good
looking and costs a ton of money
wondering how much it's 3.2 million
dollars to be exact so you can expect a
real showstopper if you ever choose to
get one the chassis of this bad boy is
made out of carbon fiber and the body
consists of a carbon fiber reinforced
polymer you can expect top of the line
performance from this car not to mention
some next level looks too
aston martin rapide e
[Applause]
aston martin is known for two things
performance and comfort aston martin's
debut electric supercar is true to the
founding principles of its manufacturer
and delivers just that you can expect
nothing short of the best from ashton
martin and their rapid e a stunning
display of expert craftsmanship and
experience is a testament to just that
in addition to aston martin's own skills
the engineers at williams advanced
engineering have added a bit of their
own touch to this beautiful supercar the
rapid e delivers 622 horsepower of
energy and showcases an acceleration of
0 to 60 miles per hour in under 4
seconds as for the comfort the rapid e
promises the aston martin at the start
of its name is a guarantee of just how
good that is going to be
dendrobium d1 if you haven't heard the
name dendrobium d1 before we don't blame
you most people don't even know the
company exists the ones that do however
live in awe of the sheer futurism and
style this company brings forward take
the dendrobium d1 for example at first
glance what appears like something
straight out of a sci-fi movie the
dendrobium d1 is actually a car whose
design was first thought of and penned
in the 90s it took ample time for this
dream to come to life and the beast it
is today as manufacturing started in
2016.
made completely out of carbon fiber the
dendrobium d1 hosts what the company
calls a protocell carbon tub we know not
exactly the best of names when it comes
to hyper cars that can accelerate from 0
to 60 miles per hour in 2.7 seconds the
top speed of the 2020 dendrobium d1ev
hyper car is 320 kilometers per hour
which by both electric vehicle and
standard hyper car standards is pretty
decent
draco motors gte
at the time of its release the draco
motors gte was the most powerful gte
model in existence and instead of an
all-out focus on speed and other niche
stats that only the performance
enthusiasts are generally concerned with
draco motors gte focuses on making their
supercars more family friendly don't let
this make you think that the car isn't
as high-end or performance friendly as
the rest of its competition the draco
motors gte can easily hit speeds over
the 200 miles per hour mark and it does
this while also providing comfort and
ease of use this impressive achievement
is achieved by the 1200 horsepower the
gte delivers enabling it to be a
family-friendly sports car ford
exuebasto mustang lithium
if you're a fan of fast and furious
movies you're probably aware of just how
iconic the mustang is in america bring
that icon into the future and we have
the ford xuebasto mustang lithium this
sweet ride offers a five power dual core
motor in addition to an 800 volt webasto
battery you'd be hard pressed to find a
sweeter ride than the mustang its
impressive internals deliver 900
horsepower of brute strength more than
twice of what the tesla model s has
also has a six-gear manual transmission
yes you heard that right you can live
your ev fast and furious dream without
having to worry about the environment
the future truly is now generation gxe
corvettes are fast sporty and cool add
750 000 worth of ev upgrades and the new
corvette is going to become the latest
and greatest electric vehicle to ever
grace the market with 700 horsepower and
650 pounds of torque the generation gxe
is widely considered to be the first
electric vehicle to ever break the 200
miles per hour barrier to make this
special car even more worthwhile you
should know that the genevation gxe has
only 75 units available worldwide now i
don't know about you but for me cars
don't get better than this audi e-tron
gran turismo
nothing says class better than audi the
audi e-tron gran turismo however takes
the word class a step further and adds
its own touch of finesse to this beauty
the audi e-tron gran turismo yes the
name is a mouthful is nothing short of
spectacular given its somewhat nimble
appearance sure the horsepower isn't
exactly bleeding edge but you know what
is the acceleration and technology this
work of art boasts the audi e-tron gran
turismo showcases an acceleration of
0-60 in under 4 seconds clocking in 3.5
seconds the external design of the audi
e-tron is just as futuristic as the tech
it hides beneath its hood you can find
the iconic audi look in the e-tron 2.
it's just turned down a notch and
instead the focus is placed on making
the car look cooler
hispano-suiza carmen
espanol suiza carmen if the name sounds
fancy wait till you look at the car this
spanish beauty has been unmistakably
inspired by aesthetic art decor and
while it does boast some timeless
classic designs there is no doubt that
this is something for 2022 the
hispano-swissa carmen is the perfect
blend of the classics and the future it
takes everything that car manufacturers
used to do right and added a bit of the
21st century in that the car isn't the
fastest by any means at a respectable
150 miles per hour top speed it is
however one of the best looking cars on
this list the real deal however is
what's under the hood as the
hispano-suiza carmen comes with a
thousand horsepower electric powertrain
a double wishbone suspension and an
ultralight carbon fiber monocoque
chassis this is more than just a car the
espanol suiza carmen is a work of art
karma sc2 the karma sc2 is one of the
latest and greatest prototypes on the
market it offers everything a person
could want speed looks performance and a
whole lot of features this car is a
mind-blowing 1100 horsepower and the
torque clocks in at an impressive 10 500
foot-pounds the karma sc2 also comes
with a 120 kilowatt hour battery that
allows for an impressive 350 mile range
getting rid of any range anxiety you
might have surrounding electric vehicles
the acceleration of this bad boy is just
as impressive and the karma sc2 goes
from 0 to 60 miles per hour in under 2
seconds if you're thinking about the
bells and whistles rest assured that the
karma sc2 comes fully loaded with all of
them including triple high definition
cameras under the windshield that are
not only electrochromatic but also offer
a full 360 degrees around the car
lotus avija
it really starts to come alive there is
actually a little bit of body roll in
here the lotus avija is the first
british electric hyper car with a price
tag of around two million dollars the
lotus avija comes blazing through the
roads with its more than 200 miles per
hour top speed and limited edition fame
there are only 130 of these beauties
worldwide and all of them are highly
sought after the lotus evija hides under
its hood a carbon fiber monocoque frame
1973 horsepower and a weight that's just
around the 3 700 pound mark this ride is
elegant and worth every single penny
the tesla roadster is the undeniable
king of electric supercars with a top
speed of over 250 miles per hour a range
of more than 620 miles in a single
charge and an acceleration of zero to 60
miles per hour in 1.9 seconds calling
the tesla roadster anything other than
mind blowing would be an understatement
these numbers blow the competition out
of the water and once you look at the
torque strength you'll be even more
surprised the tesla roadster claims to
have a torque of 7 375 foot-pounds which
is in case you're wondering 6.25 times
as much as the latest bugati kiran that
was it for this video if you liked this
video don't forget to hit the like
button and while you're at it don't
forget to subscribe to the channel too
if you are wondering which company is
secretly beating tesla click on the
video on the screen to find out thanks
for watching and see you guys soon